here in New York police have arrested a
13 year old boy and are questioning a
second teenager in the brutal murder of
a college student detectives say the 13
year old confessed to playing a role in
the killing of Barnard college freshman
tessa majors errol barnett reports
shortly after tessa majors was stabbed
to death during a struggle on these
stairs police had their sights on
potential suspects eyewitnesses seeing
individuals fleeing the park that male
was brought in for questioning thursday
when police recognized his clothing he
had a knife with him at the time of his
arrest the 13 year old who is being
charged as a juvenile was questioned by
police in the presence of his uncle CBS
News has learned he confessed to the
robbery and said he was involved in the
murder
implicating to others in the crime both
are believed to be 14 years old one
brought in for questioning the other
still at large the thirteen-year-old boy
is being charged with felony second
degree murder robbery and possession of
a weapon the young teen appeared in
family court
visibly nervous his uncle and aren't in
the room with him those who knew the
victim are remembering a talented bass
guitar player and future journalist Kris
Graham hired Tessa majors as an intern
at a Virginia newspaper seeing her
potential or she was asking me why I did
what I did how I got into journalism
were know the nuts and bolts of it first
time we met I could tell right away that
she was a special special young lady the
13-year old suspect is in custody
expected back in court on Tuesday
now if convicted as a juvenile he would
be eligible for release when he turns 21
the CBS this morning Saturday I'm Errol
Barnett